i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
los observadores aquí en france24 ya
iniciaron las campañas de vacunación
contra el cubit 19 en todo el mundo y
son muchos quienes dudan en vacunarse
entonces para contestar a las preguntas
y luchar contra la desinformación
los científicos aterrizar aumentito
[Música]
rómulo nerys es estudiante de doctorado
en biología de la universidad federal de
río de janeiro participa en el proyecto
team a los una iniciativa de las
naciones unidas en la universidad de
londres para convencer a la población y
hacerse vacunar es la primera vez que
utiliza tick tock a la red social china
que cuenta con más de mil millones de
usuarios en el mundo
un error que muchos investigadores
cometen es que piensan que entre más
hablen más estarán informando a las
personas pero eso no es cierto cuando
quiero explicar algo sobre un tema hago
este ejercicio
[Música]
cuáles son las informaciones más
importantes que necesito conocer para
evitar la desinformación
yo yo
no
ya yo
mis suscriptores tienen perfiles muy
diferentes y tienen a alguien entre sus
conocidos que tuvo kobe y se hacen
preguntas y también hay algunas personas
que no confían en las vacunas o que no
están seguros de querer hacerse vacunar
porque han escuchado muchas
informaciones falsas últimamente y creo
que hoy en día muchas personas sin
ninguna experiencia ocupan un espacio en
internet y dicen todo lo que quieren los
científicos deberían hablar de ciencia
porque eso puede reducir la confusión la
desinformación y las 6000
muchas informaciones falsas sobre la
vacuna contra el joven 19 tratan de
asustar los internautas aquí hay dos
ejemplos desencriptados para las
informaciones falsas de las hermanas que
pueden encontrar en el instagram de
france 24
efe los efectos de la vacuna kobe de 19
en acción
cuatro voluntarios para facer
desarrollaron la parálisis de bell las
publicaciones contra la vacuna del coi
19 se han multiplicado en las últimas
semanas y a menudo son una mezcla de
información verdadera y falsa que
hacemos con este primer vídeo que
muestra a un hombre desmayándose después
de haber recibido la vacuna cuando se
verifica un vídeo siempre es necesario
observar con atención los indicios en la
imagen como este micrófono el vídeo es
un reportaje de una televisión belga fue
firmado durante las pruebas en un centro
de vacunación de kobe 19 en un suburbio
de bruselas estas personas son en
realidad actores que juegan el rol de
pacientes el hombre que se desploma
finge tener un malestar vagal enseguida
un doctor explica que no es extraño ver
pacientes desmayarse tras las
operaciones de vacunación con frecuencia
las informaciones falsas que circulan en
inglés también circulan en francés es el
caso de este segundo ejemplo cuatro
voluntarios para la vacuna pzifer
desarrollaron la parálisis de bell
transtorno neurológico caracterizado por
la parálisis periférica del nervio
facial veamos más de cerca estas fotos
una búsqueda inversa de la imagen nos
muestra que ya existían en noviembre de
9 en una página del british medical
journal es decir mucho antes de que el
coi 19 fuera detectado estas fotos no
tienen entonces nada que ver con la
situación descrita pero cuidado durante
las pruebas en eeuu de 22.000 personas
vacunadas contra el cob y 19 4
desarrollaron la parálisis de bell un
fenómeno muy poco común y por fortuna
temporal entonces mucho cuidado con las
imágenes que pretenden mostrar los
efectos secundarios de la vacuna contra
el kobe 19 algunas son completamente
falsas otras ya sean sobre informaciones
exactas pero utilizan fotos fuera de
contexto para inducir al error o para
provocar miedo
en chad el acceso a la educación sigue
siendo un reto inmenso al menos del 70%
de los jóvenes son iletrados y la mitad
de los alumnos no terminan la escuela
primaria entonces nuestro observador
decidió actuar por su cuenta
a finales de 2019 leonard gamal y
estudiante de ciencias de la educación
se dio cuenta que los niños del
campamento nómada ubicado cerca de su
casa en los alrededores de nya mena en
la capital de chad no iban a la escuela
entonces junto con uno de sus compañeros
de la promoción decidió actuar compraron
una pizarra y ahora le dan clase a los
niños con los que tienen a mano cada
mañana de las semanas en el campamento y
146 niños desde los 6 años hasta niños
de 12 13 años es cierto que los más
grandes entienden más rápido las cosas
pero tratamos de hacer lo mejor posible
para que todos puedan progresar juntos
después de un año podemos decir que ha
habido enormes progresos porque antes de
que nosotros llegáramos de manera
general eran niños que no sabían mucho
francés por ejemplo pero hoy en día
pueden decir los 12 meses del año los 7
días de la semana pueden escribir su
nombre
y quién sabe
e
en cuanto a las matemáticas pueden hacer
las operaciones sencillas hay padres que
fueron reticentes porque la escuela como
tal todavía es mal vista después del
comienzo de las clases creo que todo el
mundo estaba convencido además por el
entusiasmo que tenían los niños solo
hasta este año tuvimos algunos libros
porque recibimos un pequeño apoyo de la
ong ciencia abierta en áfrica un poco de
material didáctico una pizarra alta
en tablet bots nuestro observador sueña
con poder construir un colegio sin luz y
activas ante las autoridades por ahora
no han dado resultados quieren ayudarle
no duden en ponerse en contacto con
nuestra redacción
los observadores de esta semana llegó a
su fin si quiere unirse a nuestra
reacción como siempre todos nuestros
contactos aparecen en pantalla esperamos
con ansias sus fotos y vídeos para
cubrir juntos la actualidad
internacional a través de imágenes de
aficionados hasta pronto